Transcriber: Daniel Wieber
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
ملك: مرحبا! أنا ملك.
ابراهيم: وأنا ابراهيم أخوها لملك.
ملك: كلكم رأى الآلة التي وصلت قبلنا.
هل من الموجودين من سأل نفسه “ما هذه؟”
أكيد واحد ممكن يفكّر أنّها لعبة.
لكن لا، هذه ليست لعبة.
ابراهيم: طبعًا ليست لعبة.
نحن سوف نعرّفكم على هذه الآلة،
وما هي الفكرة والفائدة من ابتكارها،
وكيف قدرنا نواجه جميع الصعوبات ونبتكرها.
وسوف أترُك المجال لملك حتى تحكي لكم عنها.
ملك: شكرًا.
بدأت قصتنا ونحن صغار.
كنا دائمًا نرى بابا يقضي
وقت طويل في غرفة عمل خاصة،
“الورشة.”
وكان الفضول يجعلنا نلحقه ونحاول ندخُل
حتى نكتشف مكونات الورشة
ونجد اجابة لسؤالنا الدائم.
بابا ماذا يفعل؟
ما هذا الشي الذي يحتاج كل هذا الوقت
والاهتمام حتى ينجزه؟
ابراهيم: وبعد محاولات كثيرة فاشلة في أن
نقتحم ورشة بابا، واقتحمناها أخيرًا.
كنا نرى آلات صغيرة تتحرك...
(تصفيق)
كنا نرى آلات صغيرة تتحرك تحت أقدامنا.
فكّرنا أنّها ألعاب، تلعب معنا.
تهرب منا ونهرب منها.
لم نكن نتوقف لعب إلا عندما نسمع بابا يصيح،
”اطلعوا برّا!”
لقد نفذ رصيد تحملكم لليوم.
ملك: لكن في أوقات كان يترُكنا ساعات نلعب
ونتفرّج عالروبوتات.
أوقات، قبل أن ندخُل،
اطلعنا برّا.
معقول كنا نزعجه.
ابراهيم: طبعًا كنا نزعجه.
(ضحك)
ملك: وجاء اليوم الذي قررنا فيه، خلاص،
يكفي اللعب. يبدأ الجِدّ.
وبدأنا رحلة البحث عن إجابات
لكثير من التساؤلات التي نطرحها بعض
ولا نجد إجابة لها.
وبدأت رحلة الاستكشاف.
ابراهيم: فبدأنا نزعج بابا ونسعى
كل أسبوع لأن ننظر إليه.
ما اسمه وكيفية عمله؟ في ما ممكن يفيدنا؟
وكنا نجد إجابات لتساؤلاتنا بدون كلل
أو تعب أو تذمُّر من بابا.
بالعكس، كان جوابنا بكل حب واهتمام.
تعرفوا لماذا؟
لأنّه كان يرى كمية حبنا
واهتمامنا وسعينا لتعلم حب الاستكشاف.
ملك: وخلال رحلتنا، اكتشفنا شيء لم نكن
نبحث عنه بين القِطع الإلكترونية والأسلاك.
تعرفوا ماذا اكتشفنا؟
اكتشفنا حبنا للروبوتات وحبنا للإلكترونيات
وحبنا لرائحة ورشة بابا.
ما أن نتذكرها نتذكر أوقاتنا
التي كانت مليئة بمشاكل وتحديات وطوارئ
ومحاولات إنقاذ من بابا قبل وقوع الكارثة.
ابراهيم: التي كُنتِ تفعليها.
ملك: أنا؟
(ضحك وتصفيق)
لكن كانت روح المنافسة حاضرة
والذي كان ينجز المهمة قبل الثانية
يشعر بفخر كبير لأنّه أنجز المهمة.
ابراهيم: طيب، أنا كنت دائمًا أنجزها.
ملك: أيضًا أنتَ؟
(ضحك وتصفيق)
ولكن أحب أن أحكي لكم، رغم تعبها،
كانت وما زالت أحلى الأوقات
التي تجمعنا كعائلة.
ابراهيم: وبالحديث عن العائلة،
أحب أن أحكي لكم أننا حظينا بأفضل عائلة،
دعم ومساندة لنا.
علمتنا أنّ الوقت كالذهب ولازم نستغله
بالعلم النافع. بالذات بجهة كورونا،
بسبب الإغلاق الذي كنا مرينا فيه
وحاولنا نتعايش معها،
لحظ بابا أنّ هناك وقت ضائع كثير
مع غير استفادة
فقررنا أن نتعلم دورات الشطرنج أون لاين
ومكامن أفضل استغلالنا للوقت.
وفخورين أنّنا أنجزنا معرض الشطرنج كعائلة.
ملك: ما توقفت جهود عائلتنا الى هذا الحد.
في يوم أهدانا بابا أعظم هدية،
وهي روبوت “إديسون” الذي من خلاله...
تعلمنا كيف يبرمج جميعة
الأوامر للروبوت ويطبقها بدقة عالية جدًا.
ابراهيم: واستمرنا في التعليم
حتى بعد عودتنا إلى المدارس.
وفي عام 2022،
عرفنا عن  مسابقة أولمبياد
البرمجة والذكاء الاصطناعي
التي أطلقتها وزارة التربية والتعليم.
وتحمسنا كثيرًا، وبدون تردُّد
شركنا بالمسابقة بفريق عائلي
مكوّن من ثلاث أعضاء:
بابا كمشرف الفريق، وأنا، وأختي.
والهدف المطلوب من المسابقات
تجد مشكلة وتجد لها حل إلكترونيًا.
تستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي
وعلم الروبوتات.
ملك: وبدأنا رحلة البحث عن مشكلة
حلها الذكاء الاصطناعي.
وبعد تفكير طويل، تذكرنا أهم مشكلة.
هي مشكلة المُزارع التي كنا نشاهدها
في كل زيارة للأراضي الزراعية.
كم كمية المعاناة التي يواجهها
في عملية زراعة البذور.
كمية التعب والتعرض للشمس
والخطر وأحيانًا الموت.
خصوصًا عند المناطق الحدودية.
كم مهمة الزراعة مهمة دقيقة
وتحتاج للوقت الطويل لإنجازها.
ابراهيم: فقررنا أن نصمّم
روبوت زرع البذور الذكي، “آغري بوت”
هذا الروبوت يحل جميع المشاكل تواجه
المُزارع في عملية زراعة البذور.
يعني نقدر نقول أنّ الروبوت أصبح مُزارعنا.
ملك: هذا الروبوت أصبح اليوم مُزارعنا
بحيث أنّه يقوم بمهمة المُزارع نفسه.
الروبوت يحفر التربة ويزرع البذور
وينزّل التربة فوق البذور التي زرعها.
ابراهيم: وليس هكذا فقط.
يعمل على الطاقة الشمسية.
يعني لا يحتاج ولا أكل
ولا شرب ولا ساعات راحة.
يعمل ليل ونهار دون توقف أو كهرباء
ويستمد طاقته من أشعة الشمس في الصباح
ويخزن فائض عن حاجته في البطاريات
استخدمها في ساعات الليل،
وهكذا حللنا أول مشكلة
وهي توفير الطاقة للروبوت.
ملك: ليس فقط هذه المشكلة التي واجهتناها.
واجهتنا مشاكل كثيرة.
من ضمنها مشكلة عدم توافر القِطع
التي للأسف ما قدرنا نحصل عليها
قبل وقت المسابقة بسبب إغلاق المعابر
واضطررنا أن نستبدلها من قِطع
موجودة في المنزل ومن الألعاب.
ابراهيم: أستطعتُ أن أصمم تطبيق هاتفي
من خلاله يتم التحكم في الروبوت
من خلال البلوتوث.
ملك: أستطعتَ!؟
أنا التي صممتُ التطبيق.
(ضحك)
(ضحك وتصفيق)
ملك: أنا التي صممتُ التطبيق
بعد تحديات كثيرة بيني وبين ابراهيم
حول مَن الذي سوف يصمم التطبيق.
فقرر بابا أنّ مَن يتلع أفضل تصميم تطبيق
هو سوف يصمم التطبيق.
وأنا التي كسبتُ التحدي وصممتُ التطبيق.
ابراهيم: طيب، مبروك.
التحديات أمامنا كتيرة.
(ضحك)
ملك: تعالوا أحكي لكم عن التطبيق
الذي أنا صممته.
التطبيق سهل الاستخدام للمُزارع البسيط.
كل مطلوب منه ادخال البيانات الخاصة
بعملية الزراعة للروبوت، مثل عدد البذور،
المسافة بين البذرة والبذرة، وعدد الخطوط.
تلقائيًا سوف يقوم الروبوت بحساب المساحة
الأرض الزراعية التي سوف يزرعها.
بعدها المُزارع يقوم بوضع الروبوت
في بداية الأرض وعطاها أمر ابدأ.
ابراهيم: وكل المطلوب من مُزارع
أن يجلس في مكان آمن ومريح
وبعيد عن خطر ويراقب خط سير الروبوت
على طريق التطبيق الذي هي صممَته.
وهكذا حللنا جميع المشاكل واجهنا
خلال فترة العمل على الروبوت
و نقدر أن نقول أنّ الروبوت أصبح مُزارعنا
وصار جاهز لدخول المسابقة.
ملك: وحان الآن وقت المسابقة، وقت المواجهة،
وقت إثبات القدرات، وقت الحصاد.
لا تستغربوا من حماسي في الكلام.
فترة ما قبل المسابقة كانت أشبه بالحرب.
إعلان حالة طوارئ في البيت.
مُصارعة حقيقية مع الوقت
الذي كان أعظم المشاكل التي واجهتنا.
كيف نقدر أن نصمم روبوت في
وقت قياسي؟ ثلاث أشهُر فقط!
طيب، ودراستنا؟ كان وقت المسابقة
قبل بدء اختباراتنا بأسبوع واحد.
طيب، ماذا نفعل؟ دراستنا مهمة
مثل أهمية العمل على موهبتنا.
تعبنا وتوترنا ونحن نحاول نجد حل.
حاولنا نعمل جدول منظم نمشي عليه.
ما قدرنا للأسف.
ابراهيم: وحان صارت سوبر ومن الخاصة فينا
التي قدرت تصمم لنا جدول بنظم الثواني
وليس فقط ساعات.
أنّها الأم.
(تصفيق)
أكيد كلنا فقدنا شيئًا وقعدنا ساعات وساعات
نبحث عليه وما وجدناه.
وجاءت أمنا وهي مغمضة ووجدته.
لا تستغربوا، أنها قوة الأمهات التي عجز
جميع العلماء عن اكتشاف مصدر قوتها لليوم.
شكرًا يا ماما.
(تصفيق)
ملك: حان الآن وقت العرض.
وصلنا المعرض وتم عرض مشروعنا.
ولا نخفي عليكم، التوتر كان سيد الموقف.
أعصابنا كانت تنهار.
ما في على لسانا إلا “يا رب.”
و ما كان يطمئننا غير بابا
وَثِقَته بمشروعنا وطول الوقت يقول لنا
“سوف نحصل المركز الأول إن شاء الله.”
ونحن، لأن بابا هو السوبر هيرو الخاص فينا،
ثِقَته بالفوز كانت يطمئننا وتريحنا كثيرًا.
وفعلًا ثِقَته كانت في محلها...
وحصلنا المركز الأول!
(تصفيق)
حصلنا المركز الأول
وجائزة المعرض الكبرى.
(تصفيق)
ابراهيم: وحان نستذكر عبارة
أنّه لكل مجتهد نصيب
فالحمد لله أكملنا بالنجاح بعد التعب.
ملك: أتمنى قصتنا تُلهِم غيرنا،
وحاولوا يطلعوا ...
من المنطقة الراحة الخاصة فيهم.
ابراهيم: اكسروا القيود
وابتكروا حاولوا تجد مشكلة
وتجد لها حل
مثلما حللنا مشكلة المُزارع.
ملك: لا تفكر أنّ مشكلة الزراعة
هي المشكلة الوحيدة التي تواجه مجتمعنا.
المشاكل كثيرة
ونحن كلنا ثِقَة سوف نجد حل لهذه المشاكل.
ملك وابراهيم: وشكرًا.
(تصفيق)
ملك: شكرًا.